[Music]
signs can make a big difference
anywhere from just a simple reaction to
a big experiment if you just find the
right application signs can save the
world
my name is gitaji li rao and i am 12
years old i'm a scientist
I invented a device called tethers that
detects lead and water faster than any
other current techniques out there today
I was appalled by the number of people
affected by light and water during the
Flint water crisis I wanted to do
something to change this for the
residents of Flint and places like went
all over the world my device includes a
core device and a disposable cartridge
with the carbon nanotube sensor you dip
this disposable cartridge into the water
you want to test you pull out your phone
open up the toughest application and
connect over bluetooth to get the
results of save slightly contaminated or
critical of lead levels in your water
[Music]
my advice to other kids who want to save
the world is do not be afraid to try I
fail at like four or five times but I
got back into the lab did again and then
it was like that aha moment when
everything kind of started coming
together and you know the device is born
I think that science allows me to look
at different approaches to solve real
world problems out there today it's
important to take other people's
problems and make something to help them
with it mainly because we're all one big
community and it's our duty to help
other people
you
[Music]